thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air which now comes
with nebula for free when you use the
link in the description
well the president has now gone to war
with Twitter because Twitter is applying
warning labels to some of his tweets
it's 20/20 so that pretty much checks
out as you may know President Trump is a
fierce critic of speech that disagrees
with his own viewpoints and don't take
my word for it take his C I don't think
that the mainstream media is for your
speech either because it's so crooked
it's so dishonest so to me free speech
is not when you see something good and
then you purposely write bad to me
that's very dangerous speech but as
president he believes that he has the
power to shut down private companies who
distribute comments that he doesn't like
d tweeted Republicans feel that social
media platforms totally silenced
conservative voices we will strongly
regulate or close them down before we
can ever allow this to happen and
President Trump has toyed with issuing
an executive order targeting online tech
companies for years but now that Twitter
has started putting warnings on some
tweets that the president tweets out the
dam appears to have finally broken the
American President issued an executive
order purporting to dictate how online
platforms like Twitter Facebook and
Instagram regulate speech online which
of course brings up the age-old debate
between platforms and publishers the
Communications Decency Act section 230
and the First Amendment so the question
is what did the president just do and
can he do it and does he understand the
First Amendment
[Music]
hate legal eagles it's time to think
like a lawyer because there may not be a
single topic more misunderstood than
freedom of speech so let's start at the
beginning the first one the First
Amendment as you may know the First
Amendment protects freedom of speech
among other things now the biggest
misconception about freedom of speech
via the First Amendment is that it
restricts what the government can do to
private individuals the key phrase in
the First Amendment text is that
Congress shall make no law this means
that the First Amendment is directed at
stopping the government from censoring
speech or compelling speech private
companies generally speaking can do
whatever they want as a regards speech
now of course there are exceptions to
this carved out by the Supreme Court for
some limited categories of obscenity and
creating imminent lawless action but
these are the tiny exceptions to the
general rule that the First Amendment
prohibits the government from
restricting private individuals or
private companies speech and the term
freedom of speech has a specific legal
meaning freedom of speech is a negative
right against the government that
prevents the government from punishing
most kinds of speech freedom of speech
does not apply to private companies
generally speaking and also generally
speaking it prevents the government from
forcing individuals to make speech that
is called compelled speech so as a
general rule as one commentator put it
the Constitution protects Twitter from
the policing of a president it does not
protect a president from the policing of
Twitter and similarly that gets into
censorship which is a different side of
the same coin censorship is when the
government restricts or prohibits
certain kinds of speech it's a
governmental action private companies
might delete comments or moderate
content and you might think that that's
a bad thing and you might have great
arguments for that but whatever that is
it's not censorship at least not in the
legal sense nor is censorship facing the
repercussions of one's own speech
the First Amendment in freedom of speech
doesn't shield you from the social
consequences of the speech that you made
so with that very general background
about the First Amendment in freedom of
speech that takes us to the
Communications Decency Act now you might
have heard of the terms platform or
publisher before generally that comes
from a certain section of the
Communications Decency Act section 230
so if you've ever heard someone referred
to 230 or section 230 what they're
probably talk
about is the Communications Decency Act
including the president who just
recently tweeted out that we should
revoke 2:30 without providing any
context now if you've ever read the
First Amendment you might notice that it
says nothing about platforms or
publishers or responsibility for
defamation that's because it relates to
the CDA which was passed in 1996 now
we'll talk about what the CDA section
230 does in just a second but I think
it's worth going over the history of the
Communications Decency Act because the
history that led to the founding of this
particular law is incredibly fascinating
and it harkens back to the very
beginnings of the internet now in the
early days of the internet there were no
laws regulating the content on the
internet and it quickly became apparent
that if people posted whatever they felt
like saying some inappropriate and
illegal things could make their way onto
the web
someone could post child pornography
some people could post incredibly
defamatory statements and not to mention
people posting things that just violate
someone's copyright and lawyers and
legislators had to grapple with whether
there would be liability attached not
only to the person that posted that
information but anyone who hosted that
information now traditionally content
distributors were not liable if they
distributed something that ran afoul of
one of the areas where speech is
restricted or has legal liability and
I'm using the term content distributors
incredibly loosely here we're talking
about historically stores and newspapers
now in the 1950s the Supreme Court
overturned a Los Angeles ordinance that
said if you have obscene material in
your store you can be held criminally
responsible for selling that
paraphernalia in particular a bookstore
owner was convicted of violating the
ordinance by selling a novel called
sweeter than life which tells the story
of a quote ruthless lesbian
businesswoman the store owner was
sentenced to 30 days in jail for simply
selling the book the Supreme Court said
that the bookstore couldn't be
responsible for reviewing every single
thing that was in the book or magazine
that it happens to sell fast forward
about 40 years with the invention of the
Internet we now have a similar but
different situation involving ISPs and
people that post content on their
websites now two of the first ISPs
CompuServe and prodigy were both sued
for hosting forums where users posted
defamatory content prodigy for example
billed itself out as a family-friendly
ISP so
moderated comments that were hosted in
its forums removing things that it
thought were bad
now CompuServe on the other hand didn't
moderate anything in its forums and as a
result the courts found that this
distinction was important but both
CompuServe and prodigy were sued for the
allegedly defamatory content that was
posted in their respective forums now
the case against CompuServe was
dismissed because the court considered
that
CompuServe was merely a Content hoster
and a distributor rather than an author
or a publisher as a distributor
CompuServe could only be held liable for
defamation if it knew or had reason to
know of the defamatory nature of the
content but since CompuServe wasn't
moderating its forums it had no reason
to know what material was posted to
those forums but things turned out
differently for prodigy the company that
wanted to be family-friendly a post
appeared on a money talk forum claiming
that the investment firm Stratton
Oakmont committed criminal fraud in
connection with a stock IPO yes that
Stratton Oakmont the one that gave rise
to the film wolf of wallstreet gentlemen
welcome to Stratton Oakmont I can't
imagine why someone thought that
Stratton Oakmont was committing fraud
but the firm Stratton Oakmont sued not
only the anonymous poster who posted the
allegedly defamatory content that in
retrospect was probably not defamatory
in any way but it also sued prodigy for
hosting that content and a court held
that prodigy was liable as the publisher
of the content created by his users
since it exercised editorial control
over the messages on its bulletin board
and unlike CompuServe which was compared
to a bookstore prodigy was considered to
be more like the editor of a newspapers
opinion page in essence prodigy was
liable because they created content
guidelines proactively enforced those
guidelines and used software designed to
remove offensive language and under this
reasoning prodigy knew or had reason to
know that the content was quote unquote
defamatory since they had those
guidelines in place and were exercising
their discretion now it's worth noting
that these weren't Supreme Court cases
these outcomes aren't necessarily
dictated by the Constitution these are
lower court opinions about the
interaction between ISPs and defamation
so these cases aren't necessarily set in
stone but early internet companies drew
a very clear lesson from these lawsuits
they shouldn't do any moderation at all
since that was the best way to avoid
liability there didn't appear to be a
middle ground between absolute
lawlessness and some kind of moderation
but before any of these cases could go
to the Supreme Court Congress actually
stepped in Congress didn't like the fact
that businesses were being held liable
for the acts of their users when
Congress finally enacted the
Communications Decency Act they were
doing that in response to the moderation
dilemma lawmakers wanted online service
providers to be able to moderate content
at the time they were especially worried
about things like harassment and obscene
material so they gave online providers
immunity from lawsuits if they moderated
their content and as an incentive for
Internet companies to create basic
standards the law granted them immunity
from liability if they simply adopted
standards and enforce them the
Communications Decency Act was
specifically created so websites didn't
need to be neutral so that takes us to
the controversial section 230 the
relevant portion of the CDA section 230
is actually very short clear well worded
and an understandable piece of law if
you go to section 230 subsection C it's
called protection for Good Samaritan
blocking and screening of offensive
material sub 1 says treatment of
publisher or speaker no provider or user
of an interactive computer service shall
be treated as the publisher or speaker
of any information provided by another
information content provider in the term
another information content provider is
incredibly important that means another
user a commenter a tweeter a person on
Facebook a person posting to Instagram
so that's the general immunity that
protects not only Twitter but someone
that happens to have a YouTube channel
or a blog from being liable for the
postings of other users and content
providers but then subsection 2 goes a
little bit further and it specifically
allows for people to moderate content on
their platforms or websites it states
that no provider or user of an
interactive computer service shall be
held liable on account of a any action
voluntarily taken in good faith to
restrict access
- or availability of material that the
provider or user considers to be obscene
lewd lascivious filthy excessively
violent harassing or otherwise
objectionable whether or not such
material is constitutionally protected
or not or being any action taken to
enable or make available to information
content providers or others the
technical means to restrict access to
material described in paragraph 1 so
let's talk about these two provisions
section 230 C 1 establishes the immunity
for third party liability under which a
website is not to be treated as the
speaker or let's say publisher of the
illegal or otherwise offensive content
posted on a web site by a third party
end user or what the CDA refers to as
another information content provider
will summarize that as you're not
responsible for what a different user
posts to your site now section C 2 also
protects web sites against any civil
liability should sites engage in
self-regulation or make good-faith
efforts to edit the web site by blocking
screening or restricting access to
basically any content that they don't
want on their web site so in other words
platforms like Twitter or Facebook or
blogs or YouTube channels can't be sued
for defamation on the basis that they
had knowledge of defamatory or otherwise
illegal content on the basis that they
moderated their content and we're going
through comments or other postings and
removing ones that they didn't like him
didn't want on their website and it's
hard to overstate the importance of
section 230 in the development of the
early internet and really as the
Internet has developed to this day
whether you agree with it or not it is a
powerful tool that provides immunity and
shields Internet service providers and
web sites from liability for content
that they host and will certainly get
into the differing opinions on whether
it's 230 is a good thing or a bad thing
but as a legal matter decades of court
decisions have affirmed the robust
immunity that is provided under the CDA
section 230 and here are a few recent
examples that show how section 230 has
been used as a shield by content
providers for example a man sued the
grinder dating app for negligence
products liability and related claims
after someone impersonated him and
posted fake profiles on the app the
court found that section 230 barred
claims against Grindr for the design
it's platform as within the purview of
protected traditional editorial
functions similarly in Wisconsin a
plaintiff sued a classified advertising
website because the plaintiff wound up
buying what turned out to be a murder
weapon from a private seller the case
was dismissed because the plaintiff sued
the website claiming that the website
was responsible for what someone else
had posted to the website and ultimately
sold to that person but the website
didn't sell the gun it just hosted the
ad for it so it wasn't responsible for
what happened to go wrong with that sale
but here's a key point that's often
misunderstood in both of those cases the
person that wrote the posts that
ultimately was misleading or illegal
they're responsible for the legal
repercussions of those posts just like
anyone that Post staff amatory content
on Twitter is responsible for the
defamation that they may have done the
only thing that the CDA section 230 does
is it exempts the platform the or the
web site from being legally responsible
for the posting of some other
third-party content user but by the same
token web sites and platforms want the
flexibility to be able to remove those
kinds of postings if they so choose if
they find out that someone is trying to
sell a murder weapon in a classified ad
they want the flexibility to be able to
remove that post if if they find out
about it so if you've ever wondered why
websites have these incredibly long
terms of service contracts that
effectively allow websites to do
whatever they want and remove whatever
content or users they want to that's why
but obviously section 230 has received
criticism on both the left and the right
there are many people who claim that
section 230 discriminates against
certain kinds of viewpoints in
particular political viewpoints and
ironically my twitter feed is full of
people on the Left who claim that tech
companies are biased against their views
and people on the right who claim that
tech companies are biased against their
views as well certainly it's not
surprising that when websites moderate
their content and their users that
people are going to claim viewpoint in
political viewpoint discrimination but
as a practical matter the vast majority
of people probably don't want true
neutral platforms it's a place of
Anarchy that's ruled by extremists and
the hecklers there's this concept in
First Amendment law called the hecklers
veto where for example you're not
allowed to discriminate against a
speaker coming to let's say a pub
forum based on the reaction of the
people that are going to view that
speech so for example if there was gonna
be a speaker at a college campus and you
knew that the college kids were going to
riots or create violence in response to
this particular speaker if you allowed
that violence to dictate who can and
cannot come to the college campus the
hecklers are allowed to veto any kinds
of speakers and so that's not a valid
basis to discriminate against someone's
viewpoint in a public forum that again
has nothing to do with a private forum
but you can imagine that there's an
analogy there too where if you're not
allowed to do content moderation that is
the extremists and the loudest voices
that are going to rule all of these
different platforms now there's a time
in a place for a 4chan or an H an I just
don't want to hang out there and I don't
think most people do either and the
ultimate irony is that if section 230
didn't exist or it was revoked and
Twitter was liable for anything that its
users posted as a result they 100% would
delete Donald Trump's account and would
not allow him to post or they would vet
all of his tweets before allowing them
to go public and we focus on the big
tech companies but it goes far far
deeper than that it's every YouTube
channel every blog any web site that
hosts comments I asked my fellow
internet lawyer Richard Hogue to talk
about what would happen if section 230
were revoked or severely curtailed hey
legal eagle it's Rick from Hogue law you
might remember me from such YouTube
videos as Coppa I just can't quit you
Kappa it's not you it's me and other
things as you rightly point out CDA
section 230 is a foundational piece of
the internet superstructure and as a
foundational piece it's important not
just to the Apple Facebook's and googles
of the world but also to places like
reset era if you're interested in
talking about video games or reddit if
you're interested in talking about video
games the language of section 230 makes
no distinction between large operators
and small which means it protects
everyone but also that a change in that
law will affect everyone and not to put
too fine a point on it but the FTC most
recently while discussing Coppa has
intimated that YouTube channel runners
like you or me are responsible for the
content that appears on those channels
as if they were YouTube itself
so what does removal of section 230 mean
it means that places like Reddit or your
channel or mine might have to be
responsible for every comment that
appears on them you might have to be
responsible for the comments that appear
on your YouTube videos I don't want that
I know you don't either now I'm not
trying to pretend that section 230 or
DMCA or Coppa descended from divine writ
and that we need to hold fast to every
bit of the language that was offered but
I do think that we need to be very
cautious about any law that affects this
many people I think Richards right the
stakes are incredibly high and revoking
to 30 could destroy the Internet as we
know it definitely check out Richard's
YouTube channel that has great analysis
about Internet and entertainment law so
that's the basics about the
Communications Decency Act but
misunderstandings about section 230
abound on the Internet so let's take
some time to dispel some of those
misunderstandings the first is of course
what about publishers and platforms
journalists politicians and internet
commentators frequently make a mistake
when they talk about CTA section 230
immunity they often say that these
internet companies are websites either
are publishers and are responsible for
the content that their users post or
that they should be treated like
publishers and held responsible for what
their users post regardless of what the
law currently is constituted but that's
not really the key distinction websites
are already liable for the content that
they create a website like Twitter or
Facebook or a newspaper like the New
York Times can and often does create
contents and when they do that they are
responsible for the legal repercussions
of the content that they create a
website can be both a publisher an
author and a platform at the same time
as the law stands they just aren't
responsible for the content of the users
or other third parties that post to
those websites or platforms nor are they
liable if they choose to moderate their
users content the law currently
recognizes that some internet providers
share some similarities to edited print
publications like newspapers in certain
contexts which are under some
circumstances held liable for third
party content however they also have
attributes of common carriers like
telephone companies
which serve as passive distributors of
third-party information under Section
230 websites are held responsible for
the content that they create themselves
but not for the content of other people
that's simply posted so this division
between publisher platform or
distributor is kind of a red herring in
the terms platform and publisher get
very very confused really when you think
of this distinction you should think of
it as the distinction between a host and
an author hosts aren't liable for other
users content but authors are always
responsible for the content that they
author sometimes a website can be an
author and sometimes a website can host
other people's content and sometimes a
website can do both at the same time you
have to look at the particular speech in
question to determine what applies in
which context and there are two other
concepts that are continually made part
of this debate that sort of get lumped
into it one is neutrality and the other
is the Fairness Doctrine now neutrality
can mean different things in different
contexts but in this context Senator
Josh Hawley has introduced legislation
that would amend the CDA section 230 so
that Internet companies would lose their
section 230 immunity if they did not
apply their rules in a politically
neutral manner this is obviously a
response to the perceived anti
right-wing bias of certain tech
companies this is one of many amendments
that are on the table that haven't
passed but potentially could in the
future query whether this sort of
viewpoint discrimination in other words
not allowing viewpoint discrimination
passes First Amendment muster because
the government generally can't mandate
that certain viewpoints be allowed or
disallowed the First Amendment has been
around for a long time and the
Communications Decency Act has been
around since 1996 so to take this action
to change it is anti conservative
because you're changing the status quo
but that's a question for another time
now the related concept of the Fairness
Doctrine harkens back to the days of
broadcast media like radio and TV which
once had a legal duty to air balanced
content covering both sides of a
politically controversial issue this was
called the Fairness Doctrine the idea
was that because you were using the
broadcast spectrum of which there was
only a limited supply the
caste networks had a duty to present
both sides now Republicans fought for
years against the Fairness Doctrine
because they argued that the balance
requirement had a chilling effect on the
delivery of the conservative message and
finally in 1987 President Reagan
repealed the Fairness Doctrine this was
considered a huge victory for freedom of
speech because broadcast networks were
no longer mandated to carry certain
messages and it actually led to the
flourishing of things like conservative
talk radio since stations were free to
broadcast views without offering other
sides of the story and while the
original Fairness Doctrine only applied
to broadcast media those generally on
the right who are detractors of the
current makeup of the Communications
Decency Act want to basically instill a
new Fairness Doctrine onto the the
public platforms that hosts users
content so with that context that brings
us to the war between President Trump
and Twitter's Jack Dorsey during the
last few weeks the president has gotten
into several Twitter Wars first calling
MSNBC's Joe Scarborough a murderer of a
former staff member prompting both
scarborough and the family of the
deceased to speak out against Trump's
comments vile people driven by hatred
and petty politics though ironically
since Trump's comments could get him
sued for defamation when he leaves
office Twitter probably would not be
responsible because they're immune under
the Communications Decency Act second
the president has been bashing states
that are promoting voting by mail during
a pandemic and as part of this feud the
president has made some wild statements
about predictions of voter fraud that
would come as a result of voting by mail
which are most likely false
now after considerable public pressure
twitter decided not to moderate the
tweets about the alleged murder but did
add some context to the tweets about
voter fraud and then recently President
Trump spent some time rage tweeting
about racial tensions in the u.s.
threatening to SiC the military on
protesters and effectively threatening
to shoot looters Twitter labeled those
tweets as promoting violence and added a
warning gate that you had to go through
both before you could actually view the
president's tweet and however you may
feel about the president's underlying
tweets or Twitter's response
more or less Twitter's decision to make
and and I would argue that the language
of the labels that they added to these
tweets would constitute something that
was authored by Twitter so the language
of the the labels that were applied if
for example those are defamatory which I
don't think people are arguing but if if
they were then Twitter would be liable
for a defamatory statement because
Twitter did in fact author those
particular tweets but that's a statement
by Twitter itself as opposed to the
statement of a third party but
regardless this action by Twitter pushed
President Trump over the edge leading to
the long threatened executive order
against social media platforms that he
doesn't agree with so let's look at the
executive order of the president now
remember an executive order can't change
the law now sometimes an executive order
can be very powerful because the
president is in control of the entire
executive branch which includes the
military and the entire administrative
state but where Congress has written
something into law a presidential
executive order cannot change what
Congress has done but that hasn't
stopped the president from trying and
this particular executive order goes
straight at section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act the executive
orders starts by making policy arguments
about what it's trying to accomplish and
make some statements about freedom of
speech in the first amendment and
remember when we started this video that
this largely is not a free speech issue
this is speech that comes from a private
party
freedom of speech relates to a negative
right against the government so for the
most part makes the classic mistake of
talking about freedom of speech when
we're talking about the speech of
private individuals now the executive
order goes on to attack the good faith
requirement of the moderation of
websites and says that because
effectively websites are making
viewpoint discrimination related to
political ideals that they're not
operating in good faith now that is the
president's opinion about what the law
says an interpretation of good faith
that is not how courts have interpreted
that requirement and that's not how
courts have made requirements for
websites that actually moderate their
particular comments so this executive
order does
carry the effect of law with respect to
what courts are going to assume about
section 230 of the Communications
Decency Act and it's possible that
Congress could change that requirement
and adopt the Holly amendments but at
the moment they haven't so this portion
of the executive order doesn't really
accomplish anything but the order does
go on to say that all federal agencies
should adopt the president's
understanding of this requirement and
effectively curtail section 230 and it
asks the Department of Commerce and the
FCC to adopt rulemaking to effectuate
that decision the FCC is supposed to be
an independent regulatory body so it's
not clear whether they will adopt this
or not
and generally the FCC has said it
actually doesn't have the power to
police the Internet in this way so we'll
see what happens with respect to that
the executive order also asked the FTC
to consider website moderation and
unfair trade practice which might result
in some action but I have to believe
that if the FTC punished websites for
viewpoint discrimination they'd run
headlong into a bunch of First Amendment
lawsuits so not clear how strong that
action would be
it also purports to create a mechanism
for public complaints about violations
of neutrality in moderation and asks for
a working group related to state
attorneys general to be able to view
state laws to prevent this kind of
moderation though traditionally the
Communications Decency Act has been
ruled to preempt state laws as well so
it's not clear what if any the the state
AG's can do in this particular context
now interestingly the executive order
also relies on a legal theory that
internet platforms are the functional
modern equivalent of a public forum and
therefore it's everyone's right to be
able to access that public forum the
theory is that the importance of social
media in public discourse means that
social media sites should be treated as
government actors subject to the First
Amendment rather than as private
entities and if websites were treated as
state actors then they would need to
follow the First Amendment just as the
government does and just like the
government they couldn't ban block or
delete content based on the viewpoints
of that particular content this of
course is the antithesis
of section 230 which encouraged private
companies to moderate content rather
than let the internet collapse into
Anarchy but at the heart of this debate
is whether websites like Twitter or
Facebook are the functional equivalent
of a town square or whether they're like
a private house now a town square
generally has been a physical location
that generally was a public good
publicly owned and thus you couldn't
restrict people from being able to
access it whereas a private house when
you own that house you can restrict as
much speech as you want
so it's it's a question of that and
there are some cases that in very very
limited contexts have applied the sort
of Town Square analogy to private places
for example certain malls and company
towns that were more like a traditional
physical public location have under some
circumstances had those restrictions
applied to them but in the vast majority
of cases where you have a private
company or a private individual whether
it's a restaurant or a commercial
building or your own private house
you're not bound by the First Amendment
and you can restrict or promote whatever
speech you want within the confines of
your own private property and sometimes
those lines get blurred there are no
easy questions in law so for example
when a government entity rents Hall for
a public forum they can't engage in
viewpoint discrimination even though
it's private property but it's sort of
been commandeered by the government or
when a governmental official uses
Twitter as the official mouthpiece of
that government agency there have been a
few cases that have said you're more
like a government than a private entity
and that's in this particular limited
channel or username but it's certainly
been interesting to see not only
Twitter's response to the president's
tweets but the president's response to
Twitter's response the choices that
Twitter makes wanted users to suppress
edit blacklist shadow band or editorial
decisions pure
simple they're editorial decisions after
having some of his tweets be warning
gated the president apparently backed
down a little bit and reversed course on
some of the statements that he was
making and you know lost in this whole
shuffle is that Twitter actually has a
First Amendment right to express its
opinion about what Trump is expressing
in his tweets now like any individual or
company or person Twitter will be
responsible for the content that they
actually author but it is of course
related to this larger context about
content moderation on websites and
platforms and when a website is
responsible for that content and not and
there are certainly advantages and
disadvantages to having section 230 on
the books it is largely responsible for
how the internet looks today whether you
like that or not
and while it's probably a bad idea to
repeal section 230 entirely what we
really need is a law that prevents
youtubers who give great legal analysis
from getting demonetized when they talk
about sensitive subjects but since that
probably isn't going to happen my
creator friends and I teamed up to build
our own platform where creators don't
need to worry about D monetization or
the dreaded algorithm it's called nebula
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream nebula is a place where
creators can do what they do best create
it's a place where we can both house our
content add free and also experiment
with original content a new series that
probably wouldn't work on YouTube in
fact if you liked this episode the
version that I put on nebula removes
this ad entirely and replaces it with an
extended discussion about the First
Amendment and section 230 forcing
website to take a speech-related action
and that by its very definition is anti
free speech you'll get a whole extended
rant that I'm not going to put on
YouTube and it's ad free and nebula
features lots of YouTube's top
educational ish creators like Thomas
Frank Lindsey Ellis and tear Zoo
we also get to collaborate in ways that
probably wouldn't work on YouTube like
Tom Scott's amazing game show money
where he puts a bunch of famous
youtubers against each other in
psychological experiments where they can
either work together or profit
individually it's amazing it's wonderful
so what does this have to do with
curiosity stream well as your go-to
source for the best documentaries on the
internet they love educational content
and education
creators and we worked out a deal where
if you sign up for curiosity stream with
a link in the description not only will
you get curiosity stream but you'll also
get nebula for free and to be clear that
nebula subscription is not a trial it's
free for as long as your curiosity
stream member and for a limited time for
less than $20 per year or $3.00 per
month you can get curiosity stream and
nebula together and since we're spending
a lot of time inside these days you
might as well do it with David
Attenborough or Chris Hadfield or just
watch Tom Scott torture your favorite
youtubers that's fine too so if you
click on the link in the description
you'll get both curiosity stream and
nebula for a ridiculously low price or
you can go to curiosity stream comm
slash legal eagle it's a great way to
support this channel and educational
content directly for just $19 per year
so just click on the link in the
description or go to curiosity stream
comm slash legal eagle clicking on that
link really helps out this channel I
really appreciate it so do you agree
with my analysis should section 230
still exist or should we repeal or amend
it leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
about pending legal issues on the
internet and otherwise so just click on
this video and I'll see you in court